when did it become so embarrassing to
just be a comedian for a living yeah
well that's the that's the Hedberg joke
what is when like you come to La as a
comedian like oh you're a comedian do
you act yeah do you write it's like oh
you're a chef do you
farm nothing to do with the thing that
I'm doing and yeah I'll get in my head
about like like comedians are superstars
now comedians are just legit like 15
years ago comedians were comedians but
they weren't celebrities right right
right right now it's like people are
doing basketball stand like on the rig
it's wild but that's like don't you
think a lot of the people though that
are doing B stadiums aren't on
traditional network television that we
were all trying to get approval of daddy
daddy yeah yeah it's all like the
YouTube people but it's but to look at
somebody like oh because you're not
playing a stadium you're not successful
as a comic like yeah yeah dude yeah hey
Andrew Schultz you
like can we all just be comedians
without having to wear capes and have
Flames when we walk out you're like
Jesus man honestly I want that outfit
but for when I sell like 58 tickets in
Omaha but I still throwing a couple
smoke bombs out
like I think you're like one of the
funniest Comics ever get that I really
do it you know what I'll take I'm trying
to be better about compliments you know
what's weird thank you you did close
your eyes so we didn't make eye contact
I actually appreciate part yeah that
part thank you
noticing this hole in the table I'm
already sweating but it's kind of like
there's when you're a comic and you
watch other people do comedy there's
like that's funny you know what I mean
like that's fun you know that's a good
joke you know oh that's funny and then
the next level is like jealousy you're
like I'll never be that good or and then
there's comedy that actually makes a
comic be a fan of comedy and just get to
be like someone in the audience yeah and
watching your last special I was just
like a person watching comedy oh that
that that means a lot thank you that's
the the nicest thing I've ever said to
anyone no even if it sounds weird
because of my personality and voice no I
even if it sounds weird because of
everything about I know it sounds like
I'm gaslighting you no I I know what you
mean though like you forget that this is
like oh I'm I'm just being entertained
like and the people sitting in the
audience yep honestly moving to Portland
has been one of the best because now I
go and I I don't watch comedy specials
on TV I'm a little worried like first
off I see enough comedy but I'm a little
worried about the osmosis of consuming
it
in the background at home or something
interesting you worry it'll affect yeah
so at least I can like have some
plausible deniability as to like the the
the originality of the stuff that's
coming out it shows cuz I mean people
say like he's West Coast to tell like
this what you know like just in terms of
how much everybody loves you and you I'm
not yeah I was going to like not not not
on the humor level nobody's touching
that we but like that's how we see you
is like the funniest guy that's like you
know just oh it's just all about the
quality um but your rhythms and like how
how you everything like wraps up and
it's so satisfying but it's so
conversational but has such incredible
jokes like it's there's no one to really
compare it to I think like I said like
being in Portland going to going to
helium there and watching my friends
come through but do their hours like you
never see anybody do an hour here you
know you see everybody do their spot you
see everybody dick around with 10
minutes minutes yeah and now I sit and I
watch what they are presenting to uh
somebody who paid to be at the club
and it's so rewarding to see the final
product like I went and saw the scar
Brothers a couple weeks ago and I've
seen them like you see them like they
get in the Rhythm a little bit with the
shorter sets but their hour I was like
howling I was like having a great time
at the with everybody else in the
audience that's awesome just having a
blast watching that and that's I think
to the set like like you know I've done
enough like oh I tried to do Edinburgh
once didn't go well but I've done some
other festiv has it gone well for anyone
ever besides Phoebe Waller Bridge has
anyone ever not somebody wins the
sparkling water award come back on Lexa
Pro I mean it's like everyone I know
that goes there like you go for 30 days
it sucks there's no one in the audience
and then you get reviewed by a
journalist yeah on a on a show that you
didn't know and there's five people
there and you got poisoning from the
black mold because my my venue was
literally a
dungeon like this is where they threw
bodies during the plague but that's
sponsored by Michelob this year whatever
whatever equivalent they got overseas
but you you watch enough of those shows
where some of it's the what do they call
it h like hamburger essays where it's
like the most basic like for a one
person show here's the introduction oh
my father sure taught me a lot of
lessons then in the middle is just your
act and at the end your conclusion
restates the introduction like and those
were the lessons my father taught me and
people like oh my God it came full yes
yes you're right you're right you're
right I watched enough of those where
like when it's done well it is really
rewarding to watch like a really fun
show that is maybe more thought out than
just these individual jokes chunk chunk
chunk yeah so and I you know I work a
lot you know I work two or three
weekends every month and so I got an
hour to figure stuff out I can't write a
lot of jokes but I could write one and
just just beat out of it Millan Asis
style until it's covering a half of the
hour well it's so well thought out do
you what's your do you like write jokes
and then start to see connections and
call backs and Story start just getting
bigger as you tell them or do you write
everything I mean you like you know when
you're like oh I'm about to repeat this
story because this group hasn't heard it
yet yeah it spice it up a little more
from last time make it fun for me you
know oh yeah yeah and then you start
doing that and all of a sudden you're
like oh man I'm telling the same story
for 30 minutes instead of 10 minutes
because you found this detail that's
funny you're like oh if I go off on this
I had this joke
about the the grocery store but I saw a
brand of something I bought once when I
was a kid and crazy thing like you start
adding all that stuff onto it yeah yeah
it just I think it just you do comedy
long enough that you start you get a
like the guy that I'm hanging out with
like know like it's weird because I feel
like comedy PE fans know more about
comedy than we do in a weird like they
do totally they'll be like oh have you
heard of this person I'm like no I don't
go on the standup subreddit I'm like oh
these people are psychos yeah and I
don't like I don't like that it's become
like it's it's it's elevating things
into like comedians are celebrities
we're not no no no I mean it's hard to
in our thing maybe yeah within our
strata yeah Pirates pirat yeah the
subreddits of like I'm going to see the
show how should I approach them
afterward should I like try to shake
their hand or something like just calm
down first off I haven't seen this
subreddit what is it don't I don't even
want to tell you about it it's not worth
it don't do it I'm like no but it's just
Reddit in again it's social media it's
not good it's an eternal comment section
is all Reddit is totally okay but it's
I'm up my own ass so I search for my
name on there you get you get big like
you know who's funny Kyle I get enough
compliments because I'm not big enough
to be torn down yet I'm like leave it
alone leave it here consistently give me
a B+ that's all I want we're not getting
we're not getting into a good college
we'll go to a state school maybe maybe
they'll give us a couple bucks that's
all we need